hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to dark cut - I must start
off by saying big warning if you're a
little squeamish this may not be for you
this is gonna be blood flying everywhere
is gonna be organs flying everywhere is
gonna be screams going everywhere it's
going to be a little bit grotesque but
that's what this game is all about you
guys requested the sequel after I played
the first one so October 26 1863 in lieu
of your training in Virginia your
transfer to the front lines comes with a
great sigh of relief there are several
soldiers who have sustained bullet
wounds who did not last long enough to
see a doctor and our numbers are wearing
thinner by the day your first patient
has a serious bullet wound to the arm
treat it and get him ready for the field
tomorrow the union is pleased to have
you Godspeed captain Robert J Gladstone
is this set in the Civil War
whiskey whiskey okay I gotta give him
whiskey he's gonna be whiskey it up holy
hell this got really intense right off
the bat okay gonna knock out the patient
with whiskey to dull the pain no no I
think he needs a little bit more that
looks pretty bad oh my god purified by
pouring alcohol directly on the wound
oh I'm so sorry what did I do
Oh open the wound up okay all right then
why didn't we do
Wow okay
I did it with one hell's left holy hell
oh my god that was way too intense right
off the bat it went from like no music
to instantaneously Celia oh my god
everything is horrible I couldn't even
think of anything to say for a second
there good job
I need like a breather after that holy
oh good job medic you are on your way to
becoming a great doctor okay let's see
what other baby wimpy person wants my
help next time October 27th 1863 word of
your last surgery has reached our
headquarters and we were pleased with
the results
good for you the Confederate Army has
pushed back our troops with their
high-power cannons we should have not
underestimated the casualties inflicted
by these machines we have a patient who
has sustained shrapnel wounds from an
exploded wagon please take care of him
immediately I thought it was a shoulder
or something I got knock him out quick
there's a drunk in this meter I didn't
even see that
I got like all the way drunk so drunk he
maybe let's well forget that this ever
happened I'm getting tuned I'm getting
into it I just need to do this first oh
man yeah knock him out get him all the
way gone I'm probably gonna kill him
without gall but hey Oh God side okay
what do I do next
dry and clean the wound
hey cut the that's why they call it dark
cut if you know what I mean
blood shouldn't be gushing out in the
open like that if you know what I mean
okay thank you
oh that does not look like a skull
fragment and what is going on outside
holy hell
I knew they'd do skin grafts in the
Civil War era
my voice is already home oh he's not
drunk anymore I gotta get a more drunk
get drunk man you're dying you have to
halt somehow fixes all the problems I
don't know how I don't make the rules
man
just get drunk just slow down there
James I get it the leather wrap if we
can do a skin graft but we got to cover
his whole head with leather
oh man I'm Anna do this Paul the elders
gonna take forever
he's getting less drunk he needs more
whiskey there we go pour alcohol on the
deeper cuts in the middle of a poor Dan
this is gonna be hard
oh holy hell okay right off the bat I'm
in a fast forward after this but right
off the bat kick him into high gear with
the alcohol man keep that [ __ ]
okay I did it alright the key was just
to keep them drunk as possible like so
much booze as any doctor would know
October 28th 1863
we have relieved you to the back lines
to let you rest we have a minor
infection we want you to look at the
patient feels like his skin is crawling
and we serious those are drugs the
patient with whiskey as usual because
he's dying for some reason he's just
right off the bat without alcohol he's
just dead this is a lesson to everybody
apparently god damn ok keep getting keep
more I need more
he needs more i I'm taking a shot he's
taking a shot we're all taking shots
it's great the Civil War was a
terrifying time cut the primary wound
God even thinking about that being
inside someone is this horrible let me
just wipe let me just wipe it up a
little bit
Oh God the second wall oh good I didn't
even know they had syringes back then oh
that looks much better
great Oh does he need more booze I think
I need more booze after this god damn
snip just good
huh would I like to live yes of course I
would then prove it
oh no on myself oh my god I was already
a little bit drunk you can tell I was
always a little bit drunk I had a few
I had a few nips have you know what I
mean I have a will to live
what will to live how do i I'm sorry I I
didn't know that I had to fill my space
bar to know that I wanted to live god
this is like oh my god
okay let me cheer my space bar which
wasn't invented in 1863 just yet and I'm
trying to pour whiskey and press the
space bar that saved up it's very hard
very hard little more booze oh do I have
to do this the whole time I have to put
I have to keep pressing the space bar
the hold okay the leg needs to go use
the bandage stool all right use the saw
Jesus good thing I have this will to
live Mike
oh you're lucky to be alive
amazing job medic you're not a doctor
yet though so screw you God have we done
are we done now that's horrible okay
proceed November 5 November 5 what is
wrong with God your bravery and will
delivers outright incredible for you to
amputate your own leg to survive is
astounding and we are ready to reward
you a medal for your bravery please
report north to our headquarters Lincoln
is preparing the highest of honors oh oh
that's it one I got a medal from Lincoln
great okay probably didn't get an
infection at all after that so that was
dark cut to I guess I'm dead what
achievements did I not get I have no
idea oh wait here we go
town drug and the Easter Egg so I guess
you guys can play this for yourself
there's obviously a link in the
description where you can check out this
game it's a lot of fun it was horrible
and grotesque but I warned you about
that I really did so you can't blame me
so thank you all so much for watching
check out dark cut 1 if you haven't seen
it already and check out surgeon
simulator it's kind of like this I guess
less realistic - anyway thanks again and
as always I will see you in the next